all right caroline welcome back
hello how's everything out to exciting
day
in a sense um just what's going on just
a relief
trying to um figure out who connected
onto my spleen
as well as my name i know that sounds
some people might not understand that
but
it's a development just happening right
now
and there's a movie set over there so i
i happen to think they have something to
do with it
but um just also i wanted to say one
thing
everybody that gets paranoid and you
know you feel like you're crazy and
stuff
just let that go when you hear this try
to
let that go into the into the
environment because um
the paranoia should be laying where it's
supposed to be
and um and but what i was saying is um
they they hooked onto my spleen and
they've been doing stuff using my spleen
because i
for some re well i was put into a
position of of power
and a they call it a holy figure i guess
or maybe even over that or it's or it
might be the organizer of it all i don't
really know but i know it it exceeds
a lot of a lot of um holiness and um
and um with with that saying said
my your spleen is what um
holds your you know judges your sins and
different things like that
so with them hooking onto my spleen and
my name
they um they've developed trying to act
like me
and it's really scary because they've
done a lot of bad stuff in the world
and um so i'm just praying right now
that they would come
clean off my spleen and off my name and
off my um
my genitals and my fertility and divert
my brain and um with with the
i've been connecting to up to above
which is a big deal whoever helped me be
able to turn my right head and
it feels like my nose or something
breaks open
but they're intercepting stuff on my
when i say prayers and stuff
and everybody's caroline yeah so tell me
what your daily
routine is my daily routine i wake up
sometimes you wake up right on the
sidewalk right in front of my studio
sometimes i wake up in random places
because i don't want to sleep in my tent
because i have so many clothes in there
and i don't
think it's their fault but people pay
money or or
yeah they do they pay money or they do
favors whatever to be connected to the
clothes in my tent
and it's just gotten out of control
because with the antichrist and the
occult and the masons i think it has a
lot to do with mason
one time i came here on a saturday
morning i think it was and
you just had a pillow and you were just
like sleeping on the sidewalk yeah
the pillow is a big deal i don't think
i've had a good pillow and people always
bring pillows and
i thank them because um but i don't know
if i've ever been able to use a pillow
but i hope that whatever
pillow's done right now it could just
maybe it's a blanket i don't remember
blankets and pillows they they grab a
bag after you wake up in the morning you
typically do what
i get up i try to get a cup of coffee
hopefully i have money
usually i don't um but i have been
lately a little bit more cause i got my
stimulus checked but
now that's gone but um then i i go and
try to get money then i i just when you
say try to get money that that means
picking up dates
yeah picking up dates and um and um
yeah i've seen you pick up guys here
driving yeah
picking up dates um which i don't really
want to be
but i feel like i don't know if i have
the energy to exert myself i'm just
learning about how they're taking
energies
because they're really doing a lot to me
it's
it's overwhelming to if you could see
um the amount of um and on your life too
and
that you even get here is beyond me
there's got to be people you don't even
know about
that are helping you to even get near me
i mean and
and i know mark really wants to thank
those people
because um it's getting to the point
where um you know
they're trying to kill the excitement
too like both me and mark probably have
our own separate feelings
right now but i could feel them just go
boop you know that's something that's
really bothering me i know these people
sweep on the sidewalk i can feel them
sweeping in my body
and i know that has to do with stealing
from me so when i'm
talking your drugs are still heroin
and some crack that's it yeah and um i
know that there's tannin in the heroin
and they've been blocking um i got the
total
um 4-1-1 today they've been blocking
every single hit i've taken of heroin
and that stuff can really help to get
rid of this technology and all this can
like if i could show you a picture of
today um
you know but they have my body in so
many different places but if i cut every
string and said i'm right here
then i got this thing and it would show
you today
um i i hate to keep interrupting you so
your your daughter is back in
is it oregon my daughter's in in malibu
oh she's in mountain
and my mom's in seattle my sister yeah
i hope she's doing good i i in every
every time i try to
send her my lever it's a constant thing
these people are blocking it i hope that
block goes
goes to nowhere and i hope she gets a
feel of that
all the time that i missed her and and
um my
thoughts are with her every second and
all my kids because i found out i have a
whole bunch of kids
because i've been living this life and i
don't even think i've been born
but i'm but i'm here and i've it's like
i've been born
so i tried to birth my you know say i'm
i'm
getting born like about six months ago i
don't really know what's
transpired but i know i'm i'm here and
i'm still alive
i don't know how many places i'm asleep
at cause i'm a really big
figure or you we could be really in a
bad
position right now are you happy i'm
happy about
um hopefully these people getting
unattached from my spleen and for them
to stop lying about me and
um and um torturing people making it
hard for people to get here
and people um blocking oh just it's
beyond i'm sure i'm sure your family
kind of got involved and tried to help
you
at one point um they've been blocking my
family from
um they've never i could tell by the
look on their face
at certain times that there's something
going on but
now i can look back and go okay there's
been something going on
you know with my family so if the people
that are looking for my family
i hope that right now because i feel a
clarity coming through
like an ocean rush of um cleaning
that they would be able to locate them
and i know these people have been lying
and acting and all the acting that's
been used um
every bit of acting that's been used and
i need to
engage my seriousness on this whole
answers if i had said i have all my
seriousness on
what would that leave the answers the
people that are looking
so um
yeah so it's just it's it's it's it's
really
screwed up because it looks like i don't
care about my family and it looks
like a lot of things but i hope they all
know i love them more than air you know
and i just um um it's
this is just a lot of emotions you've
been through a lot
yeah we've known each other about ten
years now
yeah at least maybe maybe even more but
you know i came in contact with
my it could be my first born son some
people
just like i said people you don't even
know that go and do things because they
felt like i was probably
gonna die how many children do you have
i have two children and
this you know then some imagination
imaginary well or whatever yeah
but um yeah so just with um
you know i mean i feel like i got a lot
of hope from
and and my other children around there
too that think they're not
that important but they really are the
same they're all the same
importance they're just certain there's
certain things that people
certain you know there's certain people
you can get around it um
that can bring you to different levels
that's what
it's not need that right now
i think you're i mean it's hard to watch
your deterioration since i met you
and you were yeah you were intelligent
and cogent and you were
you were just playing around with drugs
and prostitution and now it's turned
into something much more serious
and it's hard to watch you know i see
you down here i feel like i know you and
i want to help you and
i don't even know where to start yeah i
want to kidnap you
that's the thing that goes through a lot
of these people's mind i bet all of them
are thinking how can we kidnap her and
never let her get her life back that's
that's a fear but uh no i just want you
to get this life back
yeah but i don't i don't think it works
but it's a big it's a big fear
on why well i try not to show terrible
things go on with you when you were very
young
yeah and that probably set the stage for
everything that we're
seeing today yeah and and probably
might be you as well you know and people
are looking for answers and looking for
you know along with caring about
caroline it
takes care of yourself really um
to care about yourself and to try to
help yourself
before you could help me because you
can't help me
there's just i just feel like people are
twisted but i i know you've done a lot
of help
and and just maybe even your presence
here
um just weird things happen for a reason
but i know in this room
i don't hear it from the people but i'm
hearing it now which i'm really glad
that this this room's been a godsend as
well
in a big way caroline i wish you
i don't know what you need another
miracle like amanda's getting
or being offered at least and we'll see
if maybe something come along once
what's going to help you what's
happening with amanda amanda do you know
amanda the young black girl that walks
on barefoot
um i know a couple people what what
happened
she she's in a rehab now a very nice
rehab yeah
and she is uh gonna
she's got to be there for a year
okay and if she escapes or leaves or
does anything
other than stay there for a year she
goes to prison for three years oh okay
so
i hope she's i hope my understanding is
connected with that and there's
there's something going on with my chin
and my chi but i hope that amanda stays
because i just felt that
um not a presence of my you know this
whatever supposed to help people
can't help not trying to be the the boss
i'm talking about helping and i just
felt that whole connection there
with my chi yeah well i think you could
use some help too
yeah i could
all right caroline lovely seeing you
again i see you often thank you
i hope i hope she know how much i
appreciate you yeah
you don't you probably don't know it
but um i know that um i know that
there's possession on you that people
need to um
and it's almost like i feel like it's
almost like you guys
need it but you know it's bad there's a
whole bunch of [ __ ] up things
um i know that are going through your
guys's head and i know these people have
been abused
incredibly from from the time they were
born
and i hope you guys can just just even
knowing it
could open up the door to just these
people going okay
i'm not the only one and um you know
these people are all
on my side and um don't want to see me
go to hell
i guess that's the that's the um that's
the brunt of it all is um
where are you going to end up my darling
yeah you're my skid row thank you for
ages thank you
that felt good that felt good just get
that off my chest about the spleen thing
you